ja soweit oder Scholz vor gut eine halbe
Stunde in New York ja bei mir im Studio
ist jetzt Hans-Dieter Heumann von der
Bundesakademie für Sicherheitspolitik
der ehemalige Präsident der
Bundesakademie wie ist das denn
einzuschätzen würden sich Olaf Scholz
Meinung anschließen das war ein Akt der
Verzweiflung ja Olaf Scholz der
Bundeskanzler der sonst der sich eher
zurückhält ich finde mit diesem sehr
deutlichen Wort hat er recht
und zwar nicht nur wegen der
militärischen Lage
Russland sich in einer Defensive
befindet sondern auch wenn man genau
hinhört gibt es viele Widersprüche es
ist überhaupt nicht klar wer der
eigentlich eingezogen werden soll einmal
wird davon gesprochen sagt dass auf
keinen Fall Wehrpflichtige dann kommt
ein Gesetz paar Stunden später das
Männer im Wehrpflicht den Alter sich
nicht aus ihrer Stadt fortbewegen also
es ist ein ziemliches Durcheinander was
wir da beobachten
außerdem muss man das im Zusammenhang
mit den
mit diesen sogenannten Referenten sehen
die ja eigentlich für später für den
november angesetzt warenten die in den
von der Russland noch besetzten Gebieten
abgehalten werden soll gibt es
Widersprüche also Referenten da war die
Rede von
luansk und dann jetzt gut das ist der
dombas die beiden Regionen zusammen aber
auch von saporizia und herson also im
Süden da wo
unser Schwarze Meer und jetzt hört man
von Putin auch wir befreien den Donbass
also die Kriegsziele sind jetzt auch
wieder durcheinander geraten also alles
deutet auf eine auf eine Verwirrung auch
bei der Führung
hin und die ersten Folgen sollte man
vielleicht nicht übel bewerten aber
schon erstaunlich wenn innerhalb von
drei zwei drei Stunden nach Ankündigung
dieser Mobilisierung alle Flüge nach
Istanbul und ja die waren ausgebucht
sind und zwar
one way Tickets also in einem sich die
versuchen dieser Einberufung
wahrscheinlich zu entkommen interessant
ist doch auch dass Wladimir Putin der
Präsident immer noch an seinem
Verteidigungsminister Scholl GU festhält
obwohl der ja eigentlich möglicherweise
auch für diese ganze militärische Misere
die Russland gerade in der Ostukraine
erleidet verantwortlich ist
also ich würde jetzt mal brutal sagen
den braucht er noch als ein Sündenbock
wenn jetzt auch diese
Mobilisierung keinen Erfolg hat also
diese Mobilisierung Teilen Mobilisierung
ist ist eine hippiches Risiko es können
zwei Dinge passieren es kann mobilisiert
werden vielleicht sogar melden sich da
einige
aber die der Kriegsverlauf wird sich
nicht ändern das wäre also noch ein
stärkere Gesichtsverlust als es bisher
schon ist da wollte ich gerade mal
nachhaken kann der sich überhaupt so
schnell ändern kann man überhaupt diese
300.000 Menschen die da jetzt einberufen
werden sollen Reservisten die auch noch
eine Ausbildung bekommen soll können die
überhaupt so kurzfristig den
Kriegsverlauf noch aus ihrer Sicht
verändern kurzfristig nicht und man kann
daraus schließen dass Putin es auf einen
langen Krieg oder den längeren Krieg
abgesehen
hat
man muss ja auch sehen dass die
Misserfolge Russlands die militärischen
nicht darauf beruhen dass sie zu wenig
Leute haben das haben sie in der Tat und
von ihren Streitkräften haben sie ja
nach einigen schätzen bis zu 80% der
schon eingesetzt so soll natürlich
versteht man die Mobilisierung aber der
eigentliche Grund war mir nicht zu wenig
Leute nur sondern die schlechte Führung
der Armee die schlechte Moral der Armee
und dann kommt ja noch eins dazu das
fehlende Material das ja möglicherweise
jetzt auch durch die westlichen
Sanktionen eine Rolle spielt wie sehr
Gewichten sie das
fehlt das Material interessant Putin hat
ja heute auch angekündigt die
Rüstungsindustrie
beschleunigt Produkt in die Produktion
für zur Produktion für die Waffen für
den Krieg aufzuführen und da muss man
sehen da steht in einem zusammen mit
einem westlichen Sanktionen die modernen
russischen Waffen
die zum Teil eingesetzt wurden schon
brauchen bis zu 80 Prozent westliche
Vorleistungen das heißt Russland wird
auch bei einer sogenannten ankurbung der
Rüstung
Rüstungsindustrie
nicht in der Lage sein
moderne Waffen zu produzieren die sich
jetzt bräuchten während die Ukraine
immer modernere westliche Waffensysteme
bekommt aber einen Waffensystem dürfen
wir nicht vergessen in Händen Russlands
das sind die Nuklearwaffen da wurde ja
heute noch mal die Drohung von weil ich
mir Putin erneuert das sei kein Bluff
das sei eine ernsthafte Drohung glauben
Sie dass die Waffen eingesetzt werden
könnten wenn auch nur nur in
Anführungsstrichen regional und wie
würde da die Reaktion der US-Amerikaner
Aussehen geändert hat heute sind haben
beide gedroht schon und
Putin man muss das Ganze man muss ganz
genau hinnehmen hat gesagt bei einem
Angriff gegen Russland hat nicht gesagt
bei einer Eskalation des Krieges in der
Ukraine sondern bei dem Angriff
gegenüber Russland aber das hat ja auch
keiner im Westen vor und ich glaube dass
das zielt das zielt auch auf die
Bundesregierung wenn die Frage von
Panzer von der Lieferung von von
Kampfpanzer ansteht oder sogar von
weiterreichender Artillerie als die
Ukraine bisher bekommen hat dann steht
die Frage im Raum weiter reichen ja
vielleicht sogar auf russisches
Territorium also ich halte diese
Äußerung die Sie gerade da zitieren auch
für an den Westen oder besonders auf die
Bundesregierung und künftige
Waffenlieferung gezielt ja bei mir ist
im Studio noch Hans-Dieter Heumann von
der Bundesakademie für
Sicherheitspolitik dort der ehemalige
Präsident das war ja eben ganz
interessant bisher hat ja Olaf Scholz
immer wieder gesagt noch weitere
führende Politikerinnen und Politiker
die Ukraine entscheidet selbst wann der
Krieg zu Ende ist und mit welchen
Kompromissen man lebt jetzt ist er ja
eben sehr deutlich geworden und hat
gesagt wir und hat da wahrscheinlich
auch die Bundesrepublik gemeint wir
werden keinen russischen Diktat Frieden
akzeptieren ist das noch mal eine neue
Qualität oder eigentlich das was er
immer sagte also die diktatsch Friedens
hat er früher schon gesagt aber er hat
ein anderer Stelle in dieser Rede auch
gesagt dein Rückzug der russischen
Truppen man drückt das hat er bisher
noch nicht so gesagt das kann man ja
verstehen dass ein vollständiger Rückzug
bevor Verhandlungen stattfinden können
und der Bundeskanzler muss sich ja
möglicherweise morgen ich weiß nicht wie
das letzte Stand ist ja auch einer
Antrag im Bundestag Stellen im zusammen
mit den mit den mit der Lieferung von
schweren Waffen und vor allem der Frage
ob dazu Kampfpanzer
gehören da wollte ich gar nicht mal
frieren welche Rolle spielt ist
eigentlich bei der Bewertung des
Auftritts des Bundeskanzler auf der
einen Seite Dritter Jahr relativ forsch
auf hat relativ deutliche ansagerichtung
Moskau Richtung Wladimir Putin gemacht
auch in dem Statement was wir davor
hatten aber auf der anderen Seite immer
noch sagen viele zögerlich
beispielsweise bei der Lieferung richtig
schwerer Waffen die die Ukraine ja jetzt
gebraucht ja richtig also
es steht immer so sagt Handlungsbedarf
er muss sich jetzt irgendwann
entscheiden und die bisherigen Argumente
reichen nicht mehr also zu sagen die
Frage der Eskalation ist das eine aber
auch zu sagen
wir wollen nur mit anderen zusammen und
keine Alleingänge
auch dieses Argument kann er nicht ewig
verwenden weil inzwischen klar ist dass
unsere Verbündeten nichts lieber hätten
als wenn wir
auch da mal Führung übernehmen die ja
gerade die Verteidigungsministerin auch
angemahnt hat spielt da jetzt wirklich
eine Rolle könnte er das zum Anlass
nehmen und sagen russland hat eine
teilmobil machen heute verkündet das
bedeutet dann möglicherweise dass die
Bundesrepublik stärker unterstützt die
Ukraine mit schweren Waffen ja die haben
Recht die Dringlichkeit ist hat
zugenommen
man muss sich man muss das ja so sehen
wenn jetzt die Ukraine versucht im
dombas
gelernt von Russland kontrolliert das
Territorium zurück zu erobern also mit
das so formulieren dann brauchen Sie
Panzer vor allem und auch im Süden das
ist ja ein Teil der Ukraine Süd und der
Ostukraine wo Städte ist wo man
vorrücken muss und die Soldaten beim
Vorrücken schützen muss die Ukraine ist
ja jetzt sozusagen im dombas teilweise
schon zum Angreifer nicht mehr nur zum
Verteidiger geworden dazu kommt das im
Oktober möglicherweise der Boden Schlamm
wird und man ist also die Dringlichkeit
im zu der Bundeskanzler muss sich
entscheiden aber wenn ich sagen darf die
UNO Rede war nicht nur darauf
ausgerichtet sondern was ich bei dieser
UNO Rede bemerkenswert fand war dass er
die den Süden sozusagen auch
angesprochen hat ausdrücklich weil ihm
eben klar ist dass bei den 141 Staaten
die den Ukraine Krieg verurteilt haben
ist immer noch 50 bei 200 Mitgliedern
gibt die es nicht getan haben da ist
jetzt noch mal die nächste Frage
überhaupt Stellung Deutschlands im
Rahmen der Vereinten Nationen da reden
wir auch beispielsweise immer noch über
die Reform des Sicherheitsrates und ein
ständigen Sitz für Deutschland sehen sie
durch die Rede von Bundeskanzler Olaf
Scholz das gestärkt diese Position oder
war es dazu zu wenig offensiv
also die Frage der eine ständigen Rates
ständigen Sitzes im Sicherheitsrat den
gibt es glaube ich seit also seit den
Amtszeiten würde ganz Alkohols
Außenminister werden Kinkel
der das übrigens nicht sehr verfolgt hat
da muss man einfach sagen die Idee
dass noch ein Europäer im Sicherheitsrat
also außer Großbritannien und Frankreich
sitzt ist für viele aus der aus dem
Süden dann schwer verständlich aber
meiner hat sich nach hat der
Bundeskanzler eines sehr gut gemacht in
dieser Rede
er hat natürlich der rote Faden war
natürlich die regelbasierte Weltordnung
Recht gegen macht er da braucht ganz
klar gesagt dass vorher nicht so Klage
würden wir haben eine multipolare Welt
so sieht es auch Russland und China das
heißt er hat nicht gesagt die Welt ist
unterteilt in Demokratien und
autoritären das heißt er versteht dass
für viele Staaten im Süden sagen wir mal
dieser Krieg und die Frage Diktatur
nicht das Wichtigste ist sondern dass
die ganz andere Sorgen haben nationale
Interessen die damit nichts zu tun haben
der Führer der Afrikanischen Union hat
sich ja in der UNO auch beschwert dass
man unter Druck gesetzt wird hier Partei
zu ergreift die Rede von Scholz drückt
aus dass er das verstanden hat sie haben
gerade noch mal ein schönes Stichwort
genannt China da ist ja der Präsident
nicht angereist sie ist zu Hause
geblieben und trotzdem mal die Frage wie
wird sich eigentlich jetzt die Situation
dort auch in China angesichts
beispielsweise der thaimobil machen in
Russland verändern die Position Chinas
wird die so nach wie vor nach außen
zeigt es ja immer noch mal unterstützt
Russland sehr stark
rhetorisch
rhetorisch es gab mir das Treffen in so
markant jetzt die Shanghai der
sogenannten shanghai-organisation genau
da wo jetzt auch die Türkei ja
angedeutet hat dass sie da Mitglied
werden möchte genau wieder anders
Probleme NATO-Mitglied Bilder genau
Mitglied werden aber
da ist ja eines klar geworden vieler
komme ich gleich indien hat aber auf
dieser Konferenz zu Putin gesagt und
zwar ihm in die Augen gesagt jetzt ist
keine Zeit für eine Krieg das finde ich
bemerkenswert bei einem Staat der 60
Prozent seiner Rüstung aus Russland
bezieht also auch eine Abhängigkeit hat
und auch von den billigen Rohstoffen ja
momentan profitiert
stellt sich nicht offen gegen Russland
aber umgeht auch nicht die Sanktionen
was China wirklich fürchtet ist dass die
Sanktionen auch das Land selbst
betreffen es liefert auch keine Waffen
für diesen Krieg an Russland also
ich würde mit Mattia Billy sagen China
beobachtet dass sein Partner immer
schwächer wird und das ist in seinem
Interesse bei mir im Studio ist noch
Hans Dieter Hallmann von der
Bundesakademie für Sicherheitspolitik
Herr Heumann wir haben ja jetzt so ein
bisschen schon mal gesprochen
Deutschland USA Indien China wir dürfen
immer eins nicht vergessen es gibt ja
die direkten Anrainer zu Russland das
sind natürlich unter anderem vor allen
Dingen das Baltikum und Polen die auch
eine sehr starke Position gegen Russland
eingenommen haben und hat das Baltikum
heute so wird gemeldet ein Teil der
Streitkräfte noch meinen erhöhter
Alarmbereitschaft gesetzt um vor allen
Dingen sich hier abzusichern gegenüber
der
Reaktion Moskaus möglicherweise durch
diese teilmobil machen man ist ja da
auch ein bisschen eingeschlossen in
Litauen auf der einen Seite ist dann ja
sozusagen
Belarus sind die Belarussen SWR und auf
der anderen Seite haben wir dann ja eben
die Enklave Kaliningrad sehen sie durch
diese teilmobil machen auch eine Gefahr
nicht nur gegen die Ukraine sondern auch
möglicherweise Aggressionen gegenüber
das bei dem Baltikum
also ich glaube es war der der britische
verteilungsmittel der gesagt hat wir
müssen die Situation sehr ernst nehmen
natürlich müssen wir sie ernst nehmen
vor allem mit dem Blick auf eine
mögliche Eskalation
es gibt
mehrere Möglichkeiten Putin zu
eskalieren an die nukleare Optionen
glaube ich nicht die Abschreckung hat
seit 1945 funktioniert
die Nato hat selber Atomwaffen übrigens
fast noch gefährliche
konventionelle Raketen die so genau sind
dass sie auch Stellungen die russische
die Nuklearwaffen auch zerstören können
also ich glaube hier funktioniert die
Abschreckung eine andere Option wäre es
in der Tat für Russland an dich
allerdings auch nicht glaube
über den über die Ukraine hinauszugehen
und da kommt natürlich Litauen als
erstes Land im Betracht um dort
Munitionsdepots oder Sammellager für bei
Waffenlieferungen so weiter zu ich
glaube dann nicht daran
gefährlich ist es natürlich auch
wegen der Nähe von kalidingrad russisch
ist Territorium auf dem taktische
Nuklearwaffen es kann der Raketen die
konventionell und nuklear
genutzt werden können sehr wichtig für
mögliche
Verhandlungen mal dagegen aber im
Augenblick sind die da und
stünden theoretisch für eine Eskalation
mit taktischen stünden sie zur Verfügung
also ich verstehe diesen Schritt ist es
allerdings eine nationale litauische
Entscheidung keine NATO Entscheidung
noch mal vielleicht noch mal auf die
mobil machen die thaimobil machen noch
mal ein Russland eingehend heute wurde
auch noch mal vom Verteidigungsminister
gesagt schon gut dass man nicht nur
300.000 einziehen könnte soll man hätte
sogar das Potenzial 25 Millionen
Reservisten an die Waffe zu holen ist
das eine ernsthafte Drohung
also natürlich gibt es muss man erstmal
fragen 25 Millionen sind das jetzt Leute
aus der Berufsarmee die schon mal da
gedient haben das geht ja alles
durcheinander oder sind das
freiwillige oder
[Musik]
ich möchte dazu folgendes sagen
zwei Dinge einmal ist das Potenzial der
Ukraine mit 44 Millionen Einwohner aus
sehr hoch wenn wir schon jetzt mal auf
dieser Ebene diskutieren übrigens mit
einer Million erklärten Reserve die alle
zur Verfügung stehenden motiviert sind
aber ich glaube so wird sich
das nicht abspielen
man vergisst auch oft dass wenn Russland
tatsächlich ein Großteil seiner
Streitkräfte in der Ukraine einsetzt
dass das ein großes Land mit langen
Grenzen ist über 4.000 Kilometer Grenze
mit China zum Beispiel dass sie auch
schützen müssen Russland kann also muss
ja auch sein eigenes Land schützen seine
Nuklearwaffen U-Boote hat es am arg eine
arktischen mehr da dort muss er seine
Soldaten haben und ich sehe letzten
Endes ein großes riesige Putin und
vielleicht auch seine Macht dadurch die
bisherige Unterstützung der Bevölkerung
für den Krieg
80% sagt Levada die ein
unabhängigenstitut sind beruhte doch
darauf dass der Krieg nicht angekommen
war in Russland dass man ja nur im
Fernsehen erlebte wenn bei einer
Mobilisierung vor allem in Wehrpflicht
geht dabei sind dann kommt der Krieg in
Russland an dann werden die Familien
direkt betroffen sein
auch in den Regionen wir müssen nicht
nur auf petersburg und Moskau schützen
das ist ein Risiko was Putin hier
eingeht wir haben ja vorhin noch mal uns
ein Bild Auszüge aus der Rede von
Vladimir Putin angehört das ist ja schon
eine enorme Kriegsrhetorik die Erde
aufbringt teilweise hat man ja auch so
ein bisschen das Gefühl wenn man das
genau verfolgt Realitätsverlust sehen
Sie das ähnlich ist das etwas was man da
beobachten kann und kann der überhaupt
noch weil die mir Putin mit dieser
Rhetorik mit diesen Maßnahmen die er
jetzt getroffen hat kann er überhaupt
noch irgendwo zurück
also er kann er kann tatsächlich bei dem
Ausmaß der Propaganda die er
kontrolliert in Russland könnte er sagen
so
wir sind jetzt auf dem Weg den dombas
zum Kontrollieren und das war überhaupt
die ganze Zeit mein Ziel also
er kann er kann vieles sagen und dann
als irgendwas verkaufen das haben wir ja
erlebt aber sie haben die sehr wichtige
Frage
Realitätsverlust
die könnte man Männer sich nachher schon
seit Beginn des Krieges feststellen und
das berührt die Frage nach der
Rationalität
Putins ich meine das ist ja ein
klassisches Thema was ich schon in den
Königsdramen von Shakespeare finden das
irgendwann ein König ein Chef nicht mehr
richtig informiert wird entweder weil er
noch wenige Leute um sie hat oder die
dir um sich hat die können wir ja sehen
wenn die Sitzung des Sicherheitsrats
übertragen wird der Rat hat der Chef
dann sicherheitsraturuschef ist im
Grunde noch härter als er
scheuge wird gerade geschwächt
bortenkopf der Chef des FSB das sind
keine Leute die ihm die Wahrheit sagen
genau und wir haben da ja auch an der
Vorlage in der russischen Geschichte zur
Zaren Zeit die beispielsweise das
braucht man ja gar nicht zu schicks mir
zurückgreifen da kann man ja im eigenen
Land dann in Russland bleiben haben sie
doch Heumann von der Bundesakademie für
Sicherheitspolitik die Zeichen in Moskau
stehen auf sie Konfrontation wurde
gerade eben im Beitrag gesagt aber jetzt
schauen wir doch mal auf die USA da wird
ja heute so gegen 16:45 Uhr werden wir
natürlich hier bei Phoenix live
übertragen da wird sie eine Regel geben
vor der ohne Generalversammlung von Joe
Biden der hat ja in einem Interview mit
den Kolleginnen und Kollegen von CNN am
Wochenende schon gesagt zur gerichtet an
bleibt mir Putin Einsatz von
Nuklearwaffen tun sie es nicht was
glauben Sie was können wir von der Rede
heute erwarten von Joe Biden wird er da
noch mal diese durchaus deutliche
Ansprache wird er dann noch mal ein
bisschen nachlegen
also spekulieren würde ich jetzt
folgendes einmal die Botschaft die
erbringen wird die er schon im Dezember
letzten Jahres gebracht wird wir müssen
die Demokratien versammeln USA in der
Welt und wir haben überhaupt eine
bipolare Welt zwischen Demokratie und
autoritären Systemen ich glaube diese
und hier hat sich Herr Scholz ist dem ja
heute nicht gefolgt also das ist eine
Diskussion die wir auch ein
transatlantischen Verhältnis noch haben
wenn auf der anderen Seite was die
Ukraine angeht müssen wir natürlich
nüchtern feststellen dass bisher was die
militärische Unterstützung für die
Ukraine geht die USA ein durchgeführt
haben es hat nicht die Europäer geführt
das hat
die USA geführt die auch dieses Format
der
waffenlieferer
in Deutschland die sich da immer in
Rammstein treffen auch anführen
auf interessant wird werden inwieweit
oder ab wann er eigentlich mal klar sagt
was eigentlich die amerikanischen
Prioritäten in der Weltpolitik sind das
ist nämlich China
und ich will jetzt zum Beispiel
spekulieren die Frage der Lieferung von
kampfbasern durch Deutschland
es ist wahr auch die Vereinigten Staaten
liefern keine Abrams Kampfpanzer
und sie bei der Artillerie achten Sie
darauf dass die Reichweite nicht so lang
ist
so dass sie russische spiritom erreichen
kann das ganze könnte man aber auch so
interpretieren wir hätten nicht vergeben
das Kampfpanzer der Ukraine geliefert
sie sind notwendig aber hier soll
endlich mal Deutschland oder Europa in
Führung gehen aber das andeutet das
würde mich interessieren
Hans-Dieter Heumann herzlichen Dank dass
Sie heute im Studio waren vielen Dank
für Ihre Einschätzung werden sicherlich
noch oft über dieses Thema sprechen
herzlichen Dank